[Music]
I'm here on the beautiful island man in
the middle of the Irish Sea and today
we're going to explore the science and
waterwheels
and behind me is the 22-metre to Lexi
wheel the largest working waterwheel in
the world
[Music]
this wheel is over a hundred and sixty
years old and was built at the height of
the Industrial Revolution was a way to
pump water out of the lac C Line shops
[Music]
[Applause]
this mine was an integral part of the
islands economy that is Pete it employed
up to six hundred people and reduce
twenty percent of the British output of
lead zinc and copper and the trouble
with digging deep holes in the ground is
there any water likes to run in and fill
a hole up and so the lines engineered to
find a way to keep pumping all of this
water out and they've certainly done a
lot here the vertical mine shafts from
here are almost 500 metres deep so I
imagine the amount of energy required to
continually keep pumping all that heavy
water out so why can all that energy
come from
there wasn't any chrome available on the
island however one thing they do have an
abundance of here in the Isle of Man is
running water and so they built this
huge machine to harness all that
hydrological power I have to say I do
find something rather ingenious by
solving the problem of excess water by
using more water water from local
streams are fed into a pipe that leads
into the top of the wheel the water then
falls from a pipe into the buckets this
makes the wheel rotate in what is
described as a reverse direction known
as a back shot wheel this crank tells
the circular motion of the wheel into
horizontal motion and as it completes a
revolution the rod moves back and forth
a total of 2.5 metres this horizontal
motion is then turned into vertical
motion down into the mine shafts so from
a physics perspective this wheel is
simply a machine that takes the
gravitational potential energy in the
falling water turns it into rotational
energy and then into more useful
straight-line kinetic or mechanical
energy when it comes to machines though
it's more useful to think of them in
terms of their power the power is just
the measurement of the rate at which a
machine does its work how much energy it
uses per second same as you would
calculate the speed of a car in terms of
its distance travelled per hour you
calculate the power of a machine by
dividing the change in energy by time
the standard unit of power is known as a
what however for large machines like
this they usually refer to in terms of
horsepower
one metric horsepower unit is defined as
the power required to raise a mass of 75
kilograms of one meter vertically off
the ground in one second which equals
735 watts and the lack C wheel is
estimated to put out around 180 horse
powers when she's in full swing and this
is the formula to calculate the force
power of a waterwheel I know it looks
stressful but it's actually surprisingly
simple because the only operation you're
using is multiplication so this means
that if you increase or decrease one of
the factors then the power increases or
decreases proportionately the head is
the distance the water will fall the
flow is the volume of water the wheel
will capture and gravity is the
acceleration due to gravity the
efficiency of a water wheel is the
measurement of how much of its input
energy is successfully converted into
alpha energy and the light see wheels
Epson design means it's over 80 percent
efficient so just why is the waxy wheel
so damn big well as a formula before
showed the greater the distance the
water has to fall the more power is
generated and so the bigger the diameter
of the wheel the more gravitational
potential energy there is to capture
from the water so I guess the saying is
true bigger is better
modern hydroelectric dams like the
Hoover Dam are arguably the giant
descendants
water will because they to take
advantage of the movement of water
flowing downhill dams are an enormous
storage of waters gravitational
potential energy which is then captured
as it channels through turbines which
spin and generate electricity today
hydroelectric power provides almost
seventeen percent of the world's
electricity supply which is great news
because it's a very sustainable and non
polluting source of energy and to think
it all started out with a humble
waterwheel
thank you will